welcome to anicor my beloved weebs today
we're going to talk about an anime
series called planet of the beast king
an action adventure anime with
intriguing mysteries without any further
ado let's get right into it on a planet
full of carnivorous plants called
chimera twin brothers thought and rai
are running from unknown pursuers trying
their best to get out alive a few weeks
before they were watching an explanatory
transmission in a movie theater on their
home planet called yuno the transmission
explained the balkan galaxy system
consisting of the primary star balkan
and 10 orbiting planets the scientists
modified the atmosphere of these planets
to make them habitable upon walking
outside rai tells his brother that prime
minister odin wants them to become
brilliant scientists like their parents
to which thor tells him that they're
free to choose their own future suddenly
thor sent something strange there was a
blackout in their home upon reaching
they find their parents dead suddenly
the room gets filled with a weird
sleeping gas and the twin brothers fall
unconscious the perpetrators send them
off the planet through a space pod later
the brothers find themselves on this
planet some unknown inhabitants force
them to run for their lives thor
discovers a beam knife in his pocket
indicating that they must fight to get
out of the situation the pursuers
surround them and just before they're
about to attack them a man named zaghi
comes forward and tells his men to leave
them as he'll take care of them he
educates them about this planet that
it's a prison for criminals zaghi tells
thor that there's only one continent on
chimera that four ring leaders rule
women live separately from men because
they're deficient in numbers so they're
considered rare he adds that he's the
leader of wild children's nest a place
where all ages of people live as they
couldn't fit in the four rings upon
asking zaghi says that the only way to
lead this planet is to become the beast
king by defeating the leaders of all
rings after he can use a tower that
allows travel through space to reach
juno
on the other hand rai gets bullied by
people because he drops a water bucket
thor rushes to save him only to get
beaten in place of him zaghi tells thor
to leave his brother because he can't
survive here to which thor refuses they
leave this place and while travelling
thor gets annoyed by ry's constant
complaining and tells him to die people
from the okra ring surround them as they
unintentionally enter their territory
thor manipulates one of the men by
showing them his beam knife and uses
this chance to kill him rye gets
captured by one of their men thor rushes
to save him but suddenly the ground
splits and a giant plant comes out
destroying everything around it the
plant engulfs rye causing thor much
grief just when thor's about to get
killed as well a person in a robe
rescues him by using a string
thor wakes up and finds his wounds
treated a girl comes into the room and
introduces herself as tis a member of
sun ring holding the second rank
thought wonders why she saved him
although she belongs to sun ring to
which tizen says that she's impressed
because the man of thor killed was okra
rings second suddenly he remembers his
brother and tries to find him but tiz
tells him that his brother's already
dead upon walking outside he sees the
okra ring's vast stronghold in the
legendary tower he's interrupted by a
man who tries to help him but thor
refuses tears comes forward and tells
him that this man is called the third of
okra ring and he's the one who helped
him tears claims that she's chosen
thought as a husband therefore no one
will harm him but thor tells her he
doesn't want to be selected by anyone
because he wants to choose his own
destiny in frustration thor leaves only
to get lost in the vast building
suddenly everyone rushes towards the
main arena to witness try a match where
a person challenges the top of oak grey
ring tears reaches out to thor and tells
him that it's a deadly match where only
strong people survive the current top of
okra ring defeats the challenging man
with ease later a third takes thor to
the top because he wants to meet him
upon meeting him top slaps him showing
him that he's the leader here third
carries him to his room and leaves him
to grab some food for him a girl named
rika comes in and tells tears to come
back because chen the leader of sunring
is furious of her actions tears refuses
to come back and leave saying she'll
convince the top of oakride ring to let
her stay here thor tries to leave again
but tis stops him and tells him that he
can't survive outside thor tries to
escape by going through mud but suddenly
giant plants begin to grow from the soil
destroying everything around him he uses
his beam knife to hold onto one of the
branches and grabs tis his hand to save
her from falling just when he's about to
fall because of the wound opening third
comes in on a hoverbike and saves them
upon reaching oak grey ring stronghold
third treats thor's wound tiz removes a
necklace and gives it to rika indicating
that she's left her rank as a second of
the sun ring she decides to serve thor
for the rest of her life chen arrives in
okra ring along with a few attendants to
bring tis back thor walks in the forest
where tears tells him about colin a man
who came to this planet from his colony
not long before and is knowledgeable
about this planet upon thor's request
tears decides to take him to colin they
encounter chen who's bent on taking her
back on their way tis tries to reason
with her but it's all in vain when she's
going back to them thor takes tears his
knife and throws it in a nearby plant
that releases poison on chen to distract
them he takes tears and they escape the
scene on the other hand third with his
fellow are coming to rescue them on
hoverbikes thor proposed making their
own ring in which he'll be the top and
tis will be his second during their fun
talk chen intervenes and attacks them
with a dagger but luckily they're not
injured thor challenges chen by taking
out his beam knife she accepts the
challenge thinking she'll win easily
they engage in battle and soon chen
overpowers thor upon discovering the
weakness of a sword he gets up and
strikes the sword with the beam knife
that ends up breaking the blade she
decides to give tears to him because
she's lost the jewel suddenly ground
breaks and a dangerous plant comes out
and swallows one of the fellows of chen
she uses a gun to kill it but it's all
in vain thor takes the gun lying around
and climbs to the back of the plant he
fires on its main bulb causing the plant
to run in pain thor destroys its core
which leads to the death of it chen
thanks him for saving their life back in
the okra ring the top throws a party to
welcome chen as he likes her but she
doesn't take any interest in him tears
tells thor that chen nominated third in
the previous month of mating but he
refused surprising everyone top is
envious of third because of it thor
leaves the room to clear up his thoughts
and tears accompanies him third happens
to know about their own ring and asks
them joined to which thor somehow agrees
tears requests there to take them to
colin's place on hoverbikes upon
reaching a cave tears calls colin by
saying she has some friends that want to
talk with him thor tells them his full
name which turns out to be thor klein
colin is surprised to find out that he's
the son of the famous scientist klein he
tells them that odin ordered the rebel
politician party's assassination and
thor's father was on the target's list
he deliberately used this plan to kill
klein because he would become an
obstruction in his path thor was shocked
to find the truth because odin was his
father's friend while leaving colin
tells tears that he can live because of
lifeguard surgery but thor doesn't have
that surgery yet so he's most likely to
die before turning 30 which worries her
a lot soon thor and third reached the
okra ring back in the room thor wonders
why odin killed his father he leaves
again with tears to colin's cave because
he wants to confirm whether he can live
more without surgery or not upon
reaching the cave they find colin dead
as a plant had attacked him but thor
finds this suspicious because the plant
wouldn't attack in a place like this
they arrive at another party hosted by
top he tries to pick a fight with third
where he plays him calmly by obeying his
every order and able to stand here thor
intervenes and kicks the glass thrown by
tom telling him he's not worthy of being
called a leader third takes this chance
and announces that it is try although
thor didn't mean to challenge top he
realizes that third set him up for this
fight
in frustration thor leaves the party to
question third about it he punches third
telling him that he's so cruel third
tells him that he must fight top because
to become the beast king he has to
defeat all the ringleaders third tells
him about his past as a pilot trainee
and odin abandoned him here because he
took the side of thor's father he brings
thor to the battle at arena to guide him
upon reaching he shows thor a blind spot
where he must take top and then he'll
create a chance for him to land the
final blow however thor will get only
one chance and if he fails to grab it he
will die he enters the battle arena to
face him on the other hand third enters
a room located on the upper portion of
the arena to set up a sniper gun the
fight starts and top dashes towards
thought to slice him up in a single blow
but thor manages to dodge the attack
thanks to his short height he continues
to avoid his attack to make him mad
however thor's running out of stamina as
he continuously moves around top attacks
him again in frustration but thor makes
a sliding attack that makes him fall as
he's about to take him to the blind spot
top lands an attack on his shoulder
causing him to bleed top lets his guard
down as he manages to injure him thor
stands up and tries to reach the blind
spot despite getting injured upon taking
him to the spot he looks around to find
the promised chance as stated by third
but he finds nothing as he's about to
lose hope third fires to distract top
and thought uses his beam knife to land
a solid slash that kills top however he
falls unconscious as he's lost too much
blood a man treats his wound back in his
room but says he might not make it
suddenly his pulse vanishes making
everyone panic tis comes forward to
perform artificial respiration while
third performs a heart massage but
nothing seems to work third begins to
slap him in frustration and tells him to
wake up miraculously thor's pulse comes
back much to everyone's surprise a few
days later thor wakes up third gives him
the top necklace which thor refuses to
take thor feels like the life here isn't
too bad for the first time because he
has companions the scene shifts to a man
standing on a cliff in a blizzard a man
comes in and calls him top but he tells
him that he should address him zaghi
like old times zaghi tells his
subordinate that he'll conquer the okra
ring very soon
four years later zaki under the name
black wolf attacks the night ring with
his followers they end up killing the
people of this ring without any mercy
zaghi fights with their leader and kills
him with a single blow a member escapes
the ring to inform the okra ring about
the invasion from the blanc ring upon
reaching the okra ring he meets thor who
has grown into a muscular man he tells
them about the recent activities of the
blog ring and how they're killing people
and leaders of other rings he gives thor
his top necklace as he wants him to have
it third tells him that he can become
the beast king in a single move because
blog wolf has killed most of the
ringleaders tiers enters the room and
tells them that they must meet with yuki
top of sun's ring because he wants to
discuss something important about the
activities of the blank rink yuki tells
thor that they should join forces to
stop blonde wolf because sooner or later
he'll attack okra and sun rings to which
thor agrees he tells third about chen
and how she's isolated herself because
she lost one leg in her jewel
suddenly blog wolf and his fellows
attack their hiding place yuki uses a
gun to kill some of his companions while
chen moves to the top of their home to
aid him blog wolf leaves his weapon and
tells him to fight him one-on-one to
which yuki agrees he attacks blonkwolf
with his giant sword but he manages to
dodge all his attacks much to his dismay
blogwolff uses his hidden sword to land
a perfect slash on him ten comes out to
help him but his fellows surround her
just when chen is about to get killed
yuki gets up and shields her from the
bullets yuki's delighted to sacrifice
himself for the sake of chen thor and
his gang reach the place and stop them
from killing her thor tells blog wolfe
that he's broken the rules and must pay
the price for it however blonde wolf
chats with him as he knows him very well
he removes his mask and thor is shocked
to find that blank wolf is none other
than zaghi thor asks him why he's doing
this to which he answers that he should
meet him alone at the tower to learn the
truth
zaghi escapes by using a smokescreen at
home thoughts confused by zargi's
actions and regrets that he let his
brother rai die because he was a burden
to him third tells him to be wary of
zaki after all he's a human who can't be
trusted what will thor do if zaghi turns
out to be evil can he defeat him to
protect his beloved ones continue
watching from episode 7 to find more
answers